hey this is presh to Walker the net
below can be folded to make a Roman
numerical dice
which one of the following dice could
have been made as a result of folding
the net
this comes from the Oxford thinking
skills assessment paper and it's one of
the hardest admissions questions I've
ever seen
I didn't solve this question myself and
I wonder how many applicants did solve
it
now if you could cut out a piece of
paper and fold it that would make the
problem a lot easier but I'm assuming
you have to work it out in two
dimensions and just think about the
problem visually
so let's see how we can try to work out
the problem logically
we have a net which gets folded into a
Roman numerical dice
now let's look at the answer choices
all of them have the face on the right
being the number one
now this is either the number one
straight up as it's shown or it could be
rotated 180 degrees because of symmetry
of the Roman numeral one
so let's try to analyze some of the
answer choices
let's consider which ones are showing
the face too
this is answer choices B and C
now if we have one on the right and we
fold the face two to the front
but in that case we are going to have
the bottom face be number four so it
can't be like answer Choice B where 4 is
shown on the top face we eliminate
answer Choice B but what about C
well if we keep folding and then we fold
the face 3 to the top
the only question is what's the
orientation of three
if you work it out you're actually going
to have the three be parallel to one so
answer Choice C is wrong
now let's consider answer choices A and
E which show the numbers 1 3 and 5.
so 3 goes on the top it's in the same
orientation as one
now the phase five when it gets folded
the bottom of five will always align
with the bottom of three
therefore we can eliminate answer Choice
e which shows 3 and 5 in different
orientations
now if we have three on the top we need
to have the number two on the front so
we can't have five on the front answer
Choice a is wrong
so that leaves us with answer Choice D
if we knew one of the answer choices had
to be correct this would be true by the
process of elimination now in order to
get this dice we need to rotate the
entire net by 180 degrees
then if you work out the way the faces
are folded you exactly get the dice
that's shown in Choice d
so D is the correct answer
just to illustrate the answer a bit more
clearly let's actually fold this net to
make a Roman numerical dice
we'll first fold it up and we see we
have one on the right and two on the
front
we see we have three on the top so that
eliminates answer Choice B and the
orientation of three is different so we
eliminate answer Choice C
now we rotate the dice so that we're
showing the numbers 1 3 and 5. we can
see that choices E and A are both wrong
so finally we rotate the dice one more
time and we see we do in fact have
answer Choice D and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign